you're an athlete how about helping okay
we're back
uhm go for it are we ready we've got Ari
Shaffir up in this bad boy if you guys
don't know Ari he is a muscular loud
mouth if you don't worry [ __ ] you this
guy this guy about that it's Monday come
in hot you're just standing in front of
the hotel in Montreal
like one morning just with his shirt off
just with his with his regular with his
regular Orthodox at you body you look at
me from inside like there's a Sun out
well the guns are out so yeah probably
Suns are out he could have got given two
shits he's like this is my body but
these people are the industry they're
gonna look at you [ __ ] off my shirts
coming off I loved you for it they're
gonna judge you I love all right for two
reasons and I talked about this all time
one if you're the greatest cos where did
we did broke and we did Rogen's a show
and he had a bunch of CDs or like DVDs
that he was trying to sell like his
wooden show like us he doesn't say sorry
and I opened for Joe Rogan yeah and so
it was like you know how like he shakes
hands with a thousand people then Ari
are standing there with his hair it's
all like this [ __ ] giant is throwing
up and he's and he's holding these he's
holding this box of DVDs he's about as
good as marketing as I am right not good
so smartphone yeah it's also nori goes
like this alright guys you guys the guys
like I don't really have changing our
egos ah you can just take them away cuz
guys like do you take credit cards now
I've you know had money here just say
he's a cave I was not prepared for
actually would have met else it is then
I found out that you lent Bobby Lee
because he admitted it on his pocket at
$5,000 it was a lot you're such a good
guy I love when you when I hear that
about to somebody I that that's it I'm
like what a [ __ ] I love you for that
they need a little big pill popper
problem is 45 grand is a lot of money I
was a lot and then he wouldn't pay me
back when I was like lost all my money
and I did borrow money to pay rent I can
I have my money back please it's been
years is that
get to it Your Honor shelter pays five
grand a week give me my money my money
yeah well you're da baby
eventually I'll tell ya what's rear
people pay each other back these days
yeah but they're just like that he's
fine yeah oh you're good you're doing
well my money came here my money back
huh
well if somebody's super rich and you
lend them like once at my buddy Joey who
made a [ __ ] a billion dollars or
whatever he was gonna give me he goes
whatever you raise I'll double it for a
my special yeah I was like I don't know
I mean I could put 25 grand on my own
money as back him and he goes alright
I'll give you 50 on top of that and I
was like I probably never have to really
pay him back because he was making at
the time we calculated it he goes I mean
this year if you look at what I make a
day you went through this listing and he
pushed the number toward me and it said
one hundred and eight thousand dollars
today and I was like that's a lot of
money once and then after that like
they're coming like camera ten bucks
like used to owe me fifty thousand
dollars yeah no you can't pro temple or
I could say just work for a half a day
work a half a day for me there's nothing
worse that yeah we are friends like this
where when you go to dinner how many
dinners have we paid for alligator arms
and then they go all bro you did you did
have some of that appetizers all right
like yeah I think like right well just I
think another ten now if you ever want
to [ __ ] if you ever if you have a friend
who's got alligator arms and everybody
hasn't it's you know people are oh it's
no big deal but if they can't reach for
their pockets all you got to do is this
we've done it you just invite everybody
out just everybody out for a boys night
out at Nobu and just relax order the
fish have them order it just bring in
the fish man I swear to God when that
bill comes you're gonna be like who
broke all the windows and order the bag
of diamonds because this [ __ ] is like
the the bill comes and it's like 1
million you're literally like a hundred
thousand so we did that all my friends
from New York there and and guys who are
just good time Charlie's just dudes
you've met
hangers-on like we're all going to eat
on you guys guys guys who spent a lot of
time playing in a softball league and
they act here and there and they ride
them it was just a bunch of guys friends
great guys but nobody really had a real
job but their [ __ ] order and there's
a couple daddies were at the table some
of our boys were bankers and they
usually pick up the tab and they're just
[ __ ] ordering get more of those get
more that caviar with the with their and
just do all right on the side
conversation no thing so the bill comes
in it's and my buddy Jerry McFadden goes
do me a favor
calculated a person and I want you to go
around the table and whisper in
everybody's ear how much they owe and I
and it was the four hundred and forty
bucks a person whoa yeah that's how much
these [ __ ] EC people like oh yeah
nobody nobody was like so I walk around
in cherries what going his face is so
red as I'm as I'm going it's four
hundred and forty dollars in verse and
you guys would go whoa what whoa yeah Oh
and then they start fake searching can I
get my plasma oh my god how long have to
work in the kitchen for those exactly we
have one time where Rogan always pays
for everybody you know and uh first of
all we'd always wait to be like like
what do you want like um I haven't
decided to see a program or an appetizer
that means we get to also you know but
then it was like one time he had to
leave it's like can you guys it was
covered though yeah they were like we'll
pay for it so you guys cover the tip
like sure and they're like oh [ __ ] we
don't how much is a tip here oh it's
like 50 bucks to eat we don't have that
like really scrounge it together Rogan
spends money like Rogan why go order
wine I love to look at the wine and I
took the Samia he goes eh-eh [ __ ]
[ __ ] here's the Joe Rogan method of
ordering wine
what's the most expensive we'll get this
one how about I was doing Rogen on
Friday I came straight from San
Francisco that morning drove straight to
run into a podcast no Studios halfway I
was so tired and I got a nitro chick
like the coffee from Starbucks and I was
so tired I go can you put two shots in
it and lady goes yeah we don't do that
now you'll please put two goddamn shots
in there
she puts the shots in there I down it
wrote about an hour into I've eaten
anything all day an hour into the pilots
we was talking I'm like my mouth starts
salivating I'm like oh man I swear on my
life I've never been so close to
shooting my pants for that I don't know
what was going on caffeine I got I've
been sick for two like two days straight
that I was so sick man I drove as laughs
and I was like dude I gave you the
bathroom and I'll be right back I will
be right back I almost [ __ ] my pants on
the way home I'm flying down a park pool
in that slingshot and [ __ ] Jenner a
circle dude I don't know what happen in
the slingshot I almost [ __ ] rolling
studio and then almost [ __ ] the
slingshot would have been great you [ __ ]
right in that where his mouth yeah dude
yeah I don't know I was sweating so bad
and I was trying to leave like you know
I was just trying to not respond he was
asking question I was trying to get kind
of dead here cuz I wonder through the
show wrap-up yeah and then he goes yeah
you're not willing to give me let's wrap
up and I'm like I'll thank God I'm not
sure my pantyhose
wait Canelo triple G what do you think
of offering like getting to that dude I
don't know I was literally sick for two
days my mom was in town I didn't see him
didn't see him too much well yeah I
remember that you said you had food poor
you were done oh that's right yeah yeah
you might have been food poisoning plus
plus the we [ __ ] again barfing yeah MJ
I'm sorry on the toilet but naked with a
garbage pail like this oh we are to you
come on my girl walked in start laughs
just oh my god understand look so bad in
that bad shoes your balls are hanging
out
for the toys she was balls are hanging
out when you're down and out like that
it's you feel so vulnerable it was like
my body was like shaking you Xiang nan
had the pail I've never done I always
just like get up and barf into the [ __ ]
oh I don't think I told you this glassy
man I didn't tell you this but like when
we were in where was it we had that
coffee was it I got I can't remember
what tech that guy's coffee he was a fan
of ours and we went into this weird
coffee place he's like oh and his mom
was there oh no was it
Santa's no Louis Portland which I nice
oh don't you hate Chinese food and I
never told you this really but I got
sick that night and I think I told you
that I was sick I was like I never get
food poisoning I wasn't right for two
months I I every time I would eat
nauseous I thought something was
laughing remember in Austin when we were
we were there in Austin doing the show
you didn't know this one I was I was
kind of thinking I was gonna die because
I was like I would get I was basically
low-grade nauseous all the time
every day for two months I think it was
the food poisoning through my whole
bacteria just stays in you and you know
if you don't kill it that's why they
want to you know help me is I swear to
God not a commercial on it got health I
swear to God and that got you over [ __ ]
I got I [ __ ] [ __ ] down apple cider
vinegar oh really
yeah I heard blackberries is good to a
raw garlic mm-hmm when I when I travel
my travel doctors tell me things if
they're my son those taxis a three-set
three c plus one per day you're good
yeah that messes with the floor of your
gut too though
yeah whatever while he's [ __ ] and
barfing all day so you're gonna [ __ ]
die of dehydration nice to the floor of
your gun okay also you won't have to
worry about chlamydia or gonorrhea see
you can have sex with that economy yeah
my son takes care of that
I only knew it is a there's some
repercussions they take that z-pak you
tell me you tell me in your anus ages
it's just bro yeah Uranus it destroys
like these all kinds of situations are
yeah bro
so we take your poison kills a lot of
there's a lot of the good be dicker its
you [ __ ] yeah I'll take I'll take a
dish II [ __ ] depends how it is you
ever I sure have yeah I have mall time
well you have you do inner and outer
dude I get drips on the floor I will a
wiper I look down like work like it
looks like a body has been strong love
me a lot it's dripping blood you do yeah
you bit like doctors I have seen a
doctor he's like just a hemorrhoid let
me see the code of the blood and I show
me you're good oh yeah they don't need
to talk them off and burn them he can do
that because it's not gonna be
successful and it's gonna be a mess and
painful so what that is actually plug it
up you plug it up when you plug you know
when it's when it's dripping so much you
just wad up since we shove it in there
and let if I can plug up till it till
the [ __ ] geyser goes out if people
are eating right now so you have chronic
sometimes your wife and SURS just a
little bit of blood like with the brown
brown of red you know and uh oh that
should be the new nickname for you guys
big brown big red but uh a lot of brown
a little red
big brown little red sometimes it feels
like so wet that you're like wait am i
still [ __ ] and then you look at it
just soaked through red Wow just pour it
into it and they say they're like that
you're fine yes your [ __ ] doctor
doctor Mengele dude I don't know man
like like mine started off it was like a
size of one out I have a great outside
might suck cause it was hurt
yeah and then what happened I did I
started itching it like crazy and then
eventually I would keep shoving it back
in shove it back in shell I'd say it
itched it is so bad yeah I've got a lot
of itches in my life yeah I don't scale
1-10 this is a [ __ ] ten
never went away well they get sensitive
you get your scratch too much and it
starts getting sore and in a weightless
you're free it's much there are pictures
on the internet weight lifters will blow
their [ __ ] out you seen that picture
yeah one
hang out you know they're [ __ ] out
well when you're going to deadlift but
they'll blow their ass well I know that
but there's elder there idle blow the
blood vessels in their eyes I've read
out of that than this me too no Mike can
you get that picture up yeah you get
that picture chin let me see this
picture it was the power cleaning power
let's say power lifter blows his [ __ ]
I'm not sure that should do it
if that's a search that doesn't do
anything foolish sure with all the
problems blows ass out that'll help - oh
God Shemp wait video no images go images
no how can you tell
oh there it is yeah they're uncensored
see it's censored they're all uncensored
yeah these are all censored okay at the
computer maybe
type in on censored power god that guy
took a [ __ ] look down there I think that
[ __ ] in like the ring or something that
girl's [ __ ] on Censorship dude just
go to it and and you can just go to the
image and just keep you scrolling
through because that's hot okay yeah
maybe not go to uncensored go back jinn
and then I'm sure if you click on the
one that answered no that's it that's
the one that says sensor right there
that's the image yes no no damn one
doing this is sit and then over left
left left
Batman Oh God there you go there it is
oh now that's his [ __ ] first of all
nice socks I like the socks of the black
day old Steelers neither were over the
positives the next war [ __ ] that's a
disaster so you're a hemorrhoids are
like that but in a little more not the
inside now am i I don't know what's
going on that's I get that looks like
the movie tremors that looks like the
movie looks like
hey keep going like so go back up for a
second oh yeah you keep you can see a
bunch of these you can see like like go
to that guy that Joe that dude is
lifting crazy amounts of weight I don't
know I think we got it we got we got it
that would be a little good chin yeah
now think you know blow our [ __ ]
god damnit sorry what's one hassle you
you went away I want to hear about your
story about how you basically go you
know what see you later Hollywood I'm
going away without a cellphone yeah to
Vietnam etc yeah yeah that's why I take
z-pak in Myanmar some [ __ ] rebel
controlled Shan State yeah let us stay
for one night I started barfing and
[ __ ] so much aren't you worried
about your safety during this trip
worried but unnecessarily worried there
were no problems yeah the only worry I
have is cuz people look different than
me
you know when you get there and be there
for a little bit like oh this is way
safer than where I'm from
really yeah yeah I'm from Manhattan man
Alphabet City
yeah now please move there
I hear yeah it's safer in certain
certain aspects but you went where we're
exact as you go for your trip Myanmar
Thailand Cambodia Indonesia Vietnam East
Timor East Timor is no joke that's the
one I got my brother's my half brothers
in the army captain in the army and he
was like do not go to East Timor yes and
he was like it was like really I kind of
it's always kind of treating me goes you
can go to the capital Deeley maybe and
then no further east I'm telling you
that's a no you know why they say that
well because it's controlled by various
gangs from what I understand I buddy was
a with work State Department call me
James though well so so this is so weird
but the political parties hire local
martha's what he told me
local martial arts like schools yeah to
enforce they're sort of have areas
controlled by Democrats areas of control
by Republic
basic control with violent and they
basically kill you know and rape gangs
in New York yeah I was in the Indonesia
and I talked to a guy from Jakarta and I
hold on how I kind of wanted to it's too
dangerous it goes dude that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] first of all halfway there you
go to Komodo Island see Komodo dragons
and manic but he goes that's just cuz
they won't do much trade with the
Americas so the State Department's like
a still travel advisory
all that [ __ ] ended in 2006 yeah it's
illegal to say oh you're Democrat [ __ ]
you it's illegal to say that [ __ ] there
now cuz I don't want any trouble and I'm
telling you I went all the way east
I believe these Timor was great yeah
charted unless you had zero issues zero
issues in dealey maybe at night they say
be careful but like I didn't see
anything I didn't hear about anybody get
in trouble besides besides dysentery
what you worry about there is like the
water and it gives you an idea of how
important like good Civic engineering
food and water with roads there were the
worst roads
I got a think in the world definitely
the worst I've ever come across
I mean like you're on a moped driving on
a highway that's fine for a while going
like 90 kilometers an hour or something
and then all of a sudden it just starts
to get a little worse little worse and
then within like 3 miles you're just
driving on like rocks the size of shoes
and it's just like loose rocks and you
have like just up and down and then you
just gets like mud you're like 30 yards
you have to like hopefully it's not too
deep but you just like [ __ ] go for it
yeah and you just always it was great I
forgot about those roads they were great
what I just always wanted to do this I
just was like what's the luck away from
all this [ __ ] here mmm just vacation a
little bit get loose get free and what
was it what would you see the world
would you take away from it I mean a lot
of things but like besides horrible
diarrhea oh good
yeah so much good food different
different foods like stuff you've never
even seen like you know how you go to
another country and you're like they
show you like I don't know something
like oh we have a version of that yeah
that's kind of like your original pizza
or your version of hamburger I get it
everyone else yeah
these foods are I mean Asian foods are
just like different like avatar yeah
they have these wall rooms in Indonesia
that are like you know our pizza places
where it's just like they leave pizza
and then when you're like I'll take that
slice they warm it up so they do that
with meat like chopped up pieces of
different meats and then they just don't
warm it up yeah just pull out all day
yeah good yeah it sliced really Isis
keep bacteria away the beef rendang is
fun
are you seeing re yeah for sure always
always I don't know how how was your
travel I mean did did anyone like the
the white man from America I saw a lot
of other travelers I didn't [ __ ] any
locals that's the next frontier that's
not going on there really when you go to
like East Timor and Indonesia it's there
conserve the air to the white devil
they're just conservative and they're
tied to a community and so there's it's
hard to like they're not busters out
there oh that for sure I saw a guy in
Thailand
talk to a Chinese girl the white guy
talked about Chinese go through Google
Translate only end up [ __ ] [ __ ]
right it's impressive yeah you're the
real MVP Islands a little different the
Thailand is a sexual destiny ladyboys if
you don't get laid in Bangkok or Chiang
Mai it's like you're just not trying to
get laid
yeah chin you were silent Daniel 8 were
you trying to know they wanted me laid
in America do the wording shouldn't be
the worst [ __ ] in the world look at
you buddy said that he goes he client
service you know worst [ __ ] in the
world he goes disgust so I agree with
you that was so insulting I felt bad for
chin that you were saying he wouldn't
make a nice-looking woman
facial hair is too much it's like you
got no feminine giant disgusting I tried
to [ __ ] a [ __ ] I couldn't do it right
I really wanted to be able to do it I
wanted to be the guy who could do it
that's the problem I couldn't do it
either what what happened Hari just
where you're gay well English is a
problem obviously nah no cater to
tourists but did you try I tried went in
looking to do it it all came around me I
found a couple hot ones yeah
you know how much some lady boys are
like they're different than [ __ ] here
they're very different
I said to Brody Stephens I go dude this
she was playing with his hair ahead and
I said dude I'm gonna tell you right now
if you bring that chick home if you
bring that guy home my girls were out
there for that further hangover I go you
are not gay and if anybody calls you gay
I will defend you till you say that's a
best little hot woman man I've ever seen
in my life
what and Brody's like well I don't know
you know he's not gonna do it he took it
to the limit that way what does that
mean he goes let's just say he might
have I almost went all delicious yeah
like what's worse what's what's gayer
[ __ ] an uglier person or a hotter
person who both look like a women humans
a human yeah humans a human well no you
know what it would be you'd have to be
in jail with this person for a while and
then you would end up banging him no you
are you are gay man so you know
pretending is so in so he [ __ ] sends
me pictures you got buckles on his boots
he sent me a picture with a [ __ ]
Johnny with a hat with a Johnny Depp hat
it's not really quite a fedora it's like
a it's like a a wide-brimmed round it
was so cute and sexy and he's got it
propped on the back of his head where
you would wear a yarmulke like so it's
if I gotta jump through the phone my
bummer is that I can't beat him up I
can't slap him around - we sent you and
daliyah the picture sometimes I do it
just to piss you guys off
oh I was furious they don't do you think
they're homophobic is that what dude
[ __ ] you
[Laughter]
Julia send me five pictures of just
cashed rune across his bed just big big
wads of cash I just watched gay love
shooting up people do that Christ showed
me a cheque he had in Nashville he's
like really proud of it like a big
cheque you check this out he gave me a
cheque I was like oh wow I just tore it
up
well well John did you get a different
perspective traveling of those crazy
places like obviously money and like
material things aren't [ __ ] there yeah
and you come here and you hear people
talking about you like oh god I took you
guys have it so nice it's not even
beyond the I came back to DC to visit my
parents versus they don't know where it
was to you know that's good so and so it
was like just being on the metros like
this is some amazing amazing public
transportation system compared to the
garbage out there the rickety trains and
the [ __ ] you have no idea what is here
we have no perspective though no no it's
it's it's what we're custome I don't
know be like oh you you just don't
appreciate it right [ __ ] man yeah I love
the money go to Cambodia we're having
grown up in those yeah it's four months
eight grand and I wasn't skimping it was
like that's how much I spent it granted
we're staying in nice hotels know I was
thinking hostels yeah well so that is
different but you don't meet people in
hotels man you meet people in hostels
yeah and you met him you did it to Ross
yeah tour travelers I met some tours but
only values the only value of staying in
a hostel the only value is that there
are some hot hippy yeah I mean and
Swedish girls yeah
staying there looking to experience yeah
I came across a couple mostly was
[ __ ] hot German dudes [ __ ] on the
bunk bed on top of me go to go to the
shower yeah yes it was the shower it's a
shared dorm and you can hear I'm just
doing work does this play yeah it's nice
up much nicer it's nice up and you're
just like bro trying to sleep they try
to stay quiet at first you hear them
like in the moment and then you hear
like a zip and then like but then they
get more it was like oh yeah oh that was
a shot my buddy looks like me and his
other buddy looks like me just regular
guys go to Sweden when they're in
college and they're like they like dark
dudes there's always these rumors before
they like dark dude there was this rumor
all time if you go to Sweden you have
dark hair dude if they line up
mr. Barris did my favoritest guys ago
you went to Sweden to the chicks [ __ ]
huh what yeah they all [ __ ] they're all
waiting so I went there already here and
I go so how'd it go he goes well see the
thing is like they are also really
good-looking yes Gordon they have sex
with the guys I hate that but wherever
I'm going I'm gonna Trump bro the chicks
in Toronto they [ __ ] cool I think
someone got laid one yeah what's that
mean they met the one girl yeah what's
that mean the best visit my my friends
went to Australia there's a college like
dude they love the Earth Day love the
American accent they love the [ __ ] they
[ __ ] everybody then I had Israeli
friends who would like to the chicks in
Australia love Israeli accents they [ __ ]
anyone with Israeli accent and then my
English friends same [ __ ] thing they
love the English accent and then you
realize oh no Australian girls are just
[ __ ] it's true though when I was in aa
straight front way everyone's like dude
Australian girls they get down down like
all right there they do I guess yeah it
depends when it depends book on a
category you're in if you don't wanna
get laid at some point you're like yeah
I could do that anywhere yeah I actually
think that there are certain countries
where the countries you don't get laid
in other countries you're not going to
meet girls and are those countries that
are patriarchal countries that are ruled
with strict you know sort of male
overlords so yeah so if you go to
Afghanistan if you go to the certainly
you ain't gay little Russians go intense
women Russia yeah it's going Russia it's
going - it's going down your cricket
phone's going off because especially if
you're nice cuz apparently did you did
you tell me about this documentary
cousin after because so many men died in
World War one in World War two
especially World War two yeah there were
less men there were women it's a buyers
market so yeah so yeah so you know it
was especially after the war an inch
well after that they were like there was
like eight girls - one do what I watch
this documentary that you're referring
to be where these women are having
classes and they have like some just
gnarly Russian dude come in and then
why can't what do we got to do to stick
out and get a man he's based like shut
the [ __ ] up get in the kitchen when he
comes home after dinner ready and
everyone's like like what i want to do
is like well they look at a man he's
like the options the regular girls in
thailand when there aren't hookers and
that's it just hook erse or they try to
hold out but then it's like the guys
like okay I'll just go [ __ ] nine right
now yeah [ __ ] ha 30 cents yeah so the
regular girls that some more like okay I
really can't and wait five dates to [ __ ]
no it's one it's like we're gonna do it
now if you feel like doing that
Lila suck way more open yeah the bummer
about that is that I don't like that
then then you feel like girls being
bullied into it and it's not real then
it's like then they feel shitty about
themselves I don't know yeah but I just
mean like you know how sometimes here
you feel like this this social or women
might don't harass you tell me I've
liked you supposed to wait there they
just don't feel that so if they want to
[ __ ] you they just do can you give MJ
the mic MJ do you want to [ __ ] a bunch
of Thai people is there pressure on
girls here like I feel like it's gone a
little bit I think it's like fully
diminishing if anything girls are
getting more like predator like the guy
they sure are yeah it's crazy
it's a jungle sometimes I'm like I'm
kind of like freaked out by it once in a
while but I'll go through with it
women are freer to kind of explore their
own mmm I think there's still a little
pressure like I've definitely been on
those dates from like oh I'm not feeling
this at all first date and the guys
being overly creepy and I'm like oh god
this just got like level 10 escape kind
of a thing but yeah um I think it's
definitely diminishing I think girls now
especially with like feminism and
everything girls are feeling more in
their shoes to say no I'll just go to
the next guy cuz girls girls no their
phones get blown up so if this guy's a
douchebag she's like I'll just call
Uno's right after this you go on dates -
um I did a little bit I'm gonna leave if
you've gone a date and the guy goes to
the bathroom are you on your phone
checking for other dudes like that no
I've never been on a dating website
there's an article in The New York Times
about it let's see Betsy DeVos is the
she's young so who do you bone well
Instagram and that she's in school I'm
just
school and I just walked dogs and do
yoga I keep to myself right now
I'm not really hibernation kind of are
you on dating sites
no I couldn't be on those things that
cinder it was like everywhere my life
you were on tinder though yeah back when
I had a phone
it was just like but it was all day
every day anymore I have that slate that
weird like flip we see that noise oh
[ __ ] I'll get that
yeah oh because you mean I should go
through gravity 3 to repot calls in the
gravity 3 I see what you're saying the
buttons are small on the ground urges
just swiping all shins 40 is [ __ ] and he
seasons 40 yeah and he's so single so we
just we have a whole thing on today's
where the government called chinder
where we're trying to get him a date and
he's awful at tinder and you've been on
tinder bumble you gotta go for bubble
I'm on that too actually tender we have
three new matches so you guys okay
here's what you do I've got it's okay
I'm not on there so I couldn't use it
but you gotta use it you go on tinder
you've seen those girls on tinder that
are like I'm not here just for casual
Fox if you want that move on
you know swipe no whatever and then
we're all men are like well then go on
match.com this is for [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah so arms you to write on your
profile hey not looking for a sure thing
not looking for anything easy if you're
looking for [ __ ] move to the next guy
I'm here for the JIT real emotion
actions like that some along those lines
yes it's shorter than I just said it yes
yeah if you're looking to [ __ ] move on
move on move on I want to get to know
somebody
yes and then once you meet them dick pic
yes so you were killing it on the team
like I got late twice on there but it
was like all day like Society who I'd
want to match with and then I get
addicted to it a little bit yeah yeah
when you do mattress somebody it was a
cool it's like a little version of sex
it's like somebody willing to say like
yeah I'd [ __ ] you yeah well especially
starting to get more famous like I would
imagine it'd be easier I'm now probably
be easier that was 2 or 3 years ago now
you got legit [ __ ] fans and a lot of
them be interesting yeah take it man
well Bobby Lee he was like dude I just
put my resume on there
aren't you afraid they're gonna
recognize you I want in a recognized way
easier that's why I see all these comics
that picture their front pictures with
them with Conan O'Brien while they get
set could be like oh you somebody that's
crazy yeah why no Dane is on it I think
he was talking on tinder yeah yeah I
mean there's certain comics that are why
not he's if I seen going on and he's
holding together so well so loading in
your is always good friends of everybody
[Laughter]
trained a nature to the comedies throw
away I thought it wasn't very good
yeah I mean you started off as a door
guy yeah but that's where nobody went to
the store you were there then you were
there not even a tail into that like in
the middle of that you got there yeah
that's right
it was just like dark there wasn't many
people there so dark dude it was so
nobody would go there we go you couldn't
start shows on time because we'd be like
9 o'clock comes like really have four
people in the audience I got way too
late
yeah so depressed how much we're just as
good as there now yeah really
nobody's Brogan and Diaz and everyone
was a little worse but kind of stopped
you know when Rogan and the Carlos
Mencia even before that that's what it
was death that's right dead it is bad
and you're working the door there yeah
the weekdays was like [ __ ] yeah you see
people will you sell them a ticket like
it's gonna get show like yeah and then
some awful awful comic get on first and
they turn them look at you like it's
wrong maybe worse it was many good I
said wait till after this guy I remember
I remember doing shows in the original
room literally at like with four twelve
alcoholics yeah and and three tourists I
did a half hour one time for two Israeli
guys and they're both going
that allows like I said I've ever done
in my life literally you can kill in
front of two or five like we can't
always said that we should do crazy I
remember the Baris Kenny overdrive oh
yeah dombarris had a fake air band
affair guitar band and and we would play
our keyboardist
Mike my daughter was just born and my
wife was like you have to come home I
was like the band a bit easily well the
road three in the morning cuz I'd be
playing in the band ear band yeah and
she then I played the violin and that
first show you would do at the kind of
day after myself I would hang around cuz
I'm a loser and then then they do lose
dom would be like we got a very special
guest in the audience I'm betting that
guys I don't so well I should not come
on she's not you guys right now it's not
about me now he left the band he was in
the band and they left but we he's back
and we had this whole thing he and I was
and we'd be like so good to see it Donny
be like sobriety done which shake has to
be really tense and I and they give me
my axe and I put it on but in the middle
I would play a violin I play the
smallest piano in the world and then I
would play I would play a baby I'd pull
a baby out and play the middle warm and
I would blow on its stomach and that
would be part of it I will throw the
baby in the audience and they catch it I
did this was him before this I did this
forties I did this I was in the band
that was an active member for three
three four years if you're wondering why
my career didn't pull over the [ __ ] up
whenever it does this cuz I spent that
did that [ __ ] at night they said that
last year one five or that the clear
glass tattoo and then at two from two to
two forty five the the manager had to do
paperwork so he's like kid clone
yeah dude you'd be that so 245 people
you start while I'm a store when I 1999
till Wow
his employee two thousand six or seven
something like that I love it you know
what I love Atari he doesn't have an
inflated sense of himself he could give
a [ __ ]
you're a straight forward on the yeah
he's like yeah I work there I worked
there for seven years there anyway
why do you think they come she was just
booming now
well Academy get can't chasers change
talent coordinators and then also a
combination of like people on podcast
telling stories from back then of these
crazy days of getting blown in the back
and [ __ ] I I hooked up with this girl
in a darkroom Katie in this dark room
and the belly room is abandoned and then
I got a call from the manager wasn't
there
Adam was now the talent corner he goes
Katie huh and I was like nope I don't
know what you're talking about cuz he
wasn't there you know I wasn't even on
that day goes he goes yeah in the belly
rooms like no he goes this video footage
Mike wouldn't we get cameras you guys
yeah we just got cameras like he was
dark he goes night vision and he goes go
to the manager's office right now
they're looking at on on loop oh [ __ ]
yeah and I go back there and there's
watch me [ __ ] before today everyone
watches now you gotta go find the dead
spots it's a couple dead spot you gotta
like walk along the wall I hope I found
it yeah I do I did so much before 2006 I
see so much [ __ ] there Wow
I was dude I know Callen was like we
know about I'd be like I'm going to my
private room you guys cover the door I
think Locke did they shut me in one time
over and set off the alarm Jose yeah I'm
locked in they're like dude you can't I
was like I got my girl what I was well
they're all of us all of us yeah well in
the set of the most of us we were great
I was already great I was pretty good I
put up some who else is good Mike Young
yeah Young was Korea yeah long was good
Mike Young but you would do these things
where he would just like see a girl they
he was a magic man he could talk for 10
seconds and then I'd see him disappear
incredible and then see them both come
down 20 minutes later disheveled Mike
Mike
yeah and I see Mike like what'd you just
do to fro yeah Mike likes TV blue eyes
same thing like if he starts talking to
a girl yeah if Mike Young starts talking
to a girl or Stevie blue I starts
talking to a girl I'm telling you right
now I I the deal is City over you know
who else was like that [ __ ] dove
Davidoff back and of yeah we're like
crazy numbers yeah dove and I had some
adventures there was a thing where it's
like where you see some new hawk
ahem around a lot but I might try to
[ __ ] her she's been hanging out she's
gotta turn me on it's like oh yeah it's
either dove or cowling got there no yeah
it was Rogan hanging around before Rogan
hooked up with his girl his girl when he
was young man he was a [ __ ] werewolf
he got there - yeah but then he had one
he got his girl that was it he was just
like you know he's got you know kids to
change everybody yeah they're everybody
but like man he was everybody got so
good
you'd get to the point where it's like I
find her triple e [ __ ] somebody I'm like
hit Triple E do you have like committee
or anything right now I just want to
know I'm getting into heroes be like oh
just because somebody's [ __ ] a lot of
guys you can't have sex I'm like no cuz
they [ __ ] the guys I know yeah no I
know their dad [ __ ] we used to do oh my
god I can't even go into it I mean I
mean Bret Ernst was alright back before
I said well they're back when he was
younger I remember taking a girl in the
bed any time you took a girl on a tour
house all these rooms are closed the
main room is closed but but but unlocked
the belly room was closed but in law
school I mean but let me show you around
the place and that was just game over
you take into a dark room I saw IMed
once standing on the stage in the main
room I was gonna get like a ladder to
change the sign sure I saw him there's
like why is he standing there it's just
standing looking out in a dark room and
I looked down so somebody's blowing him
looking out the room I knew that girl
the tour guide if you want to show you
this room no no I was I was appalling in
my behavior but what a great time I am
you would go now because you know you
know both sides of the hallway people
talk and then you have to walk through
they walk in between you yeah you would
always like I'm just gonna show this
girl how many sir yeah I had sex with
his way it's like I'm about to [ __ ] but
I don't say this in front of the school
yes I'll just say I'm giving her a tour
and that was it like Wow way to go man
up and down I had to help her out
not one time one time in you know
there's that little room that there's a
in the original room there's a trellis
yeah that crevice there's a curtain mmm
took care to care business there while
the show was going on they're like what
do you like we're such animals guys
girls like what are you the girl for two
people to stand I'm like let me show you
this oh look at that
whoops Lord back you miss those days at
all yeah for sure the store now is nice
because packed but I love those days
dirty Wow yes dirty also we we just do
whatever going even non-sexual we had we
had a foosball table my green or the
belly room we will just play there you
would walk the steps like it smelled
like men's sweat we're all there
screaming and people dude there's a show
going on in here well I will tell him to
talk louder yeah so true is chaos we had
this thing where I would call it cocking
where I just try to rest my balls on
someone's arm or hand most the only guys
because it's like sexual yeah yeah my
friend Jim painter would always like
distract people you'd be like oh what's
that billboard on the high you feel this
thing on your arm you wouldn't know you
have no concept it would be a ball so
you look it was so great bad good time I
was trying to work up a boner when they
were playing when they were playing
foosball corner like really vigorously
working it up and I think and then like
before we go down cuz it's so non-sexual
would you go hey guys what you up to
with this bucket straight out club when
I didn't even know him that well he was
sitting there and hollows is me who know
yesterday is well been yesterday may as
well yeah and we were shooting we were
doing the 10 minute podcast and we just
started he just was standing there and
you could just see like his nose and his
big heavy [ __ ] California dick and
he's got a dick on of me no way
by the way Dalila guys I got - Leah -
Leah I got the Leah's my number one dick
[ __ ] no he blue eyes and no
so yeah we'll listen I've seen your dick
and you seen my dick and we do pretty
goddamn well kill I don't say so myself
D'Elia [ __ ] Dwarfs us rebellion of
dragons you got you and I are 155 pounds
and he's a heavyweight yeah he's got
he's got what oh no what the world yeah
that's right no by the way might be
number one him and David Blaine might be
number one as far as there's numbers but
he he was it I just saw his [ __ ]
stupid beacon owes his beaky nose and
that lazy half-mast [ __ ] hammer hog
oh so it was very impressive saw it it
was hard it was it what you only see it
not it was not small mass but it was it
was it was yeah with a bend to it I was
like that I started clapping oh and
that's very impressive
no no don't kid yourself don't kid
yourself
this feels good he's reaching he's been
further down everybody's Road
he's reaching he's really love when you
see just you know something you see
woman that's just so hot that you almost
like takes like literally takes your
breath away like like and you can't
believe it that's an li you see it once
in a while you know yeah and sometimes
you see it the calm restore you like wow
look what and then behind her just pops
up in arms over kiseliov like oh yeah of
course yeah yeah I wouldn't girl like
that be around and it's so true he
brings it in duh
and the rest of us animals it's almost
like going to the loo hey man thanks
would let me look at that three of them
are there at the same night he's been
there and he's like I go few of you he
goes yep sure have I like to crush and
come he's the best he's got a disease
here mark Norman's have a disease but
like the best is when girls come to [ __ ]
D'Elia
they're like he's on the line up the
comic store I think he's hot I'm gonna
[ __ ] the Lea I'm a 9.7
yeah no one looks like me I'm gonna go
[ __ ] krisily oh yeah they get ready
shave they do it all and then they go
out he finished a set they go walking
out as a knife
point-seven who Swedish owns the world
yep you go out there like hi Chris nice
to meet you is like oh nice to meet you
- he looks I met some other 9.6 pops up
a 9.8 pops up yeah and a 9.7 parson and
they all look each other like what the
[ __ ] the first time and he's lazy
Trump's it with a 10 that he had come
there from Instagram okay no tax things
like work for it you guys work for [ __ ]
is the best way to describe the girls
that that you're talking about are the
kind of girls that you don't know them
you don't you know them very like you
met him couple times and you might move
them in your house you might move them
in thank you yeah you're like move in
I'll figure we'll figure it out yeah
that hot yeah but then I want I want
them to start fighting with each other
I've never seen it yeah wasn't me like
get catty and start pushing yeah and
then I want I want to film this sketch
with Dalia it's kind of like Hunger
Games where he's just walking along and
all these tens our [ __ ] fight would
have maze and [ __ ] numchucks and our
[ __ ] fighting HRT over him and we're
gonna call it the thirsty games thirsty
games like you know like a Royal Rumble
yeah yeah lazy about it he just drinks
coffee and hangs out on this phone
that's what he does
he'll spend a whole day by his pool with
his 2 stupid dogs and he just sends me
texted him just he'll send me a text
message just his face giving me the
thumbs up I'm like I'll Drive your house
in the PU oh there's Dan he [ __ ]
kills me yeah I haven't seen him forever
really I we talk what do we do we're on
the thread with him we do you mean yeah
we talk every day in the New York vibe
just different huh all right yeah
they're really uh yeah I do how's that
Gotham like two months ago
yeah they like the workout scene there
is different it's it's a similar to LA
but it's different because it's just
like I don't know like New York Comedy
is still counterculture mm-hmm here it's
like show Casey mm-hmm they still saw
it's you know talk about percentages but
like there's it's it's like dark it's
dangerous it's even in mostly it's in
basements since there's a mark - right
is it smarter D this is more connected
to the world or no yeah it's less
connected they have jokes no they have
jokes they have dumb people jokes they
have likes like political comics but
it's just like let's get to it and it
doesn't matter what you look like really
when you leave a show in New York if
you're an audience member you tell your
friends I want to show someplace like
what would you hear what jokester hear
what like was it good tell me a good
joke and then here if you're always been
relieved a show your friends ask like
who was on mmm you know it's just it's a
little different that's all it's mostly
still guys just making jokes but like
there's no actors trying comedy in New
York yeah you know that's very but
there's still some great comics here
it's just like percentage different
that's all yeah yeah I love it there
though that's where I stories that
tonight you did right I started the
comic strip and stand-up New York and
and that was still there what's the big
one the sellers that were homicide but
the comic strip back when I was there
was amazing really I'm dying now it is
where you hold was there a pen and who's
managing it but the comic strip used to
be the spot Merrigan is everything huh
yeah it really is it really you can see
it when the palms start getting worse
member that what happened I found out Oh
got sold and they trying to say skimp
here they're like you need somebody who
cares about comedy and knows comics and
understands lineups and understands
difference we tell and hacks I can't
even tell through Instagram the way they
mark it yes
what else do Marcia yes Oh what kind of
Club it is yeah yeah and you can stand
up New York
Stan of New York would be great you'd
see greg Giraldo you'd see louis c.k
you'd see everybody up there you see
Dave Attell I mean so those two uptown
clubs were just as good as it's a good
workout no one's gonna be there and
bother you do your spot you run I go to
the stand mostly yeah and in the cellar
insane of New York joy deers were saying
the lake obviously he loves the Comedy
Store he's like I can't work things out
there because people go that's the
problem because the lineups are so
insane like I can't just try new
material that's a problem now if I'm in
between [ __ ] Callen and and and I
don't know correct Fitzsimmons it's like
it's not just a workout like everyone's
doing well and everyone's packed to see
these these people it's like it just
[ __ ] around yeah I almost when I was
here before I used to call him for
late-night spots then I was like let me
have it when there's only 30 people in
the room you can work it out so I can
actually like try some
from some drunk Cowboys yeah we're gonna
be into it yeah yeah I miss those days
in New York I'm just thinking of further
than you Stan New York is the first time
I ever did stand-up and I really I have
it on tape somewhere you really yeah oh
you got to put that out there black and
white No hey I gotta find a VHS my head
I was so young and my voice was so high
I was so afraid really I did really bad
jokes when's the first time you did
stand-up Ari
I did it once in in Northern Virginia
there was like some over mic I always
wanted to try it we hungry I was in
college it was like 22 23 what you go to
college university Maryland no [ __ ]
really yeah and so you went to your
first open what were you terrified yeah
terrified were three-piece suit I didn't
know there's no I didn't know they don't
you just wear jeans and a t-shirt or the
only one dressed up you weren't nervous
were you yeah were you know buddy dude
he did stand-up for the first time I
swear to God like think about how scary
it is right you didn't it'll like open
myself here I can try I was throwing
this [ __ ] up in front of 1,200
people a thousand we're that nervous I
don't know it just didn't seem nervous
you'd get up there and just do it I
guess cuz you thought you were just
telling stories first own stories you'd
also been in front of a camera and in
front of an audience before correct well
not like this but it's experience with
people looking at you yeah exactly so do
you think that that was what it was cuz
cuz that's so terrifying for so many
people but you never seen like I never
was very syphilis safety nets like my
path has been so different like god I
basically have training wheels on right
like it's a it's a finalist out there
alone dude yeah but it's fun kid fanbase
on the funny uncle at the barbecue if I
really [ __ ] up we can make a joke I'm
the on the meathead try and stand up
dude yeah at least the attempted it yeah
I have all you have all those excuses
yeah it's just art does not excuse still
going up there alone in front of [ __ ]
a thousand people that want you to be
funny yes yeah but it's it's weird
though cuz I don't think about somebody
bombing it's almost seems impossible cuz
like you're you're a funny person enough
that to be a stand-up
I mean you wrote something ahead of time
yeah so that's even better and you're
performing for an audience who was like
yeah we're here to laugh yeah yeah
so this is great so you someone who's a
funny guy prepare and I'll be ready to
laugh and then when that doesn't happen
at all it's like what went wrong you do
well like I regret fix him and say and
it actually helped me out and we're in
the back goes people are here to laugh
who can't make them laugh here they pay
money guys laugh there's literally here
just to [ __ ] life it's like you know
what he can't make me a lot for the
Comedy Store should not [ __ ] be up
here yeah though yeah I gotta reconsider
this job yeah I had to set the laugh
yeah the laugh act I was like oh man I
should just like write off in the PCH
and die yeah I was so I was so
embarrassed when I see these like they
had this soap stars who were doing
stand-up oh yeah they all decided to
raise if there's a million they were Oh
was at the Comedy Store and uh his
good-looking guys and good-looking girls
and they were trying to be funny they're
garbage man oh [ __ ] man oh man oh man
really yeah and then then you'll get a
girl who's like an actress and she's in
acting school and she did a scene that
was really funny their friends are all
like you should try stand him and she's
like my god you know what my friends
always tell me I'm super funny and then
she'll get up and she'll try stand-up at
the Comedy Store at some some show that
somebody's putting on and you know she
gets a dose quickly of of reality what
really goes on how many [ __ ] shows you
got I mean between the two of you being
at the Comedy Store and uh New York how
many [ __ ] shows have you guys seeing of
people do you know right when he said if
you're like dude like do you help them
out you like this pryzen for you no no
no you let them figure out their own
because otherwise I'll resent you
forever for saying it but it's like
you'll get it and it will teach you yeah
right quick probably a lot like hey I
want to be in UFC do you golf try it
once oh [ __ ] yeah you do that's right
yeah you do that
Brendon the dead people come up going
dude I'm an athlete I want to fight and
Brendan goes try it anyone's dreams you
know Jane was like come down challenge
me I'll [ __ ] beat you you'll find out
you're so good you'll beat me then right
so come down I'm here all day that's
right you'll find out right quick you'll
find out right [ __ ] quick how and I
think stand up is that that same thing
and then there's also that thing of you
if you were kind of good to keep working
at it if you're kind of good at fighting
keep training you're maybe you'll make
it to the big show we would have guys
when I worked the cover booth that would
come on the open mic night on pot luck
we called it and they're like I'm
[ __ ] I'll kill this [ __ ] I'm so funny
it's always like real bravado dude so
usually Andrews I just put me on like
okay we'll put you on the light comes on
in two and a half minutes you have 30
seconds to wrap up like that's the
normal three minutes and then we just
wouldn't light them and they're trying
their best they're failing at one minute
and they're failing hard at two minutes
and I'm looking for that like one minute
look four five six sweating that cold
sweat that goes in and out at the same
time and then just leave them up there
it's like lights almost a little more
about six minutes gets longer mean that
people who thought they could do what we
do yeah like [ __ ] you fine do it then
get you it yeah it's right there go
ahead I love those actresses are come
and start to her economy my name is
Ashley and so you just like guess what
they're gonna say I let my friends
smash late did they call you smash like
what yes dude I saw what the worst would
be when we were younger I well of course
when I mention names but usually be a
female comic god bless and there would
be a showcase blast like she's already
got that preneur because it's so hard
for like it cuz there's so much pressure
on a young girl cuz we have a lot of
time and young girls like you're pretty
naughty and you're gonna get a TV show
so you'd see that goes and and I would
watch and it'd be a showcase and
showcases we're always like when you
were younger when they actually meant
something back in the day cuz you could
get a huge deal or a TV show off a
15-minute showcase or a 10-minute
showcase off you stand up yeah
because they would go I made my fortune
doing that so what they would do is they
would go I mean over ten minutes you're
great and we want to create a show for
you that he's easy he's so marketable so
good funny but I made I don't want even
go into it but I paid my way for
literally seven years just just
showcasing I get a deal Wow
back in the day so
these girls these girls would get up
there get up there and they would and
one time I had two times I remember
watching just it was like a big deal
their manager would be their agent
they've literally been massaging their
shoulders go and they go out there and
they be trying their stuff and you know
what they weren't funny yeah and you
know what it is in New York and LA don't
give two [ __ ] and it would get quiet
it'd be the first minute and then it was
a second minute then Thurman and it
would just be an immediate industry an
industry when you're showcasing for
industry they're standing there with
their middle finger go well I've seen
everything but and so they come out and
they would just burst into tears like
it's it's similar in the fighting where
everyone thinks they can do it right
yeah they're waiting
they've been in a fight maybe in the
schoolyard or they've watched a million
UFC fight yeah they you know they're the
funny guy in the classroom their friends
were he told him to do stand-up you know
I bet I remember Rogen was talking to
Patrick Cote A's I think Patrick Cote
his manager is that the LaGrant market
rate that's a mat yeah and he goes uh
and you know at that time nobody's
touching Anderson Silva you know because
I don't know man he really believes he
can win and I was like okay but doesn't
Anderson Silva also believe he can win
no no but then you have this thing we
like I feel I think I'm gonna win and I
mean you don't like to follow I mean you
know better than take a punch in the
face oh yeah an idol though you know I'm
gonna do see something like good [ __ ]
why did you because their parents don't
think but you can compare yourself to
like turn on the radio heads because she
can hear she's hearing something
different yeah people are tone deaf they
think they sound great until you yeah
you put yourself up against it the joke
I do I swear to God I love my kids so
much I think they're the cutest things
that to me when they were especially
five and three or whatever the cutest
things of all time for me like you
burned there its primordial burning in
your head and the joke is I saw them in
a group of like 40 kids I swear to God
and I went my kids are middle of the
road there I think this is all for hey
but I was like then that is there that
that child objectively is a cure
what their eyes are this big and blue my
kids are my kids are average looking the
way their dad is now my wife's hottest
[ __ ] yeah but for me it was like
whatever but I do was stand up like
someone to watch let's say they watch
your special on Netflix or yeah you know
watch Dave Chappelle they don't realize
what it took to get there yeah all right
they have no I'd like you're not up
there just shooting the [ __ ] which are
the story yeah you know or like when
someone watches a UFC fight like oh it's
fighting you don't realize what that guy
went through to get to that exact moment
that - and I'm surprised a UFC guy can
do Taekwondo as well and I see him do a
back kick like chocolate doll I go
that's a really good backache I've never
seen him throw that in a fight and you
go and Brennan goes he's a professional
dude so when you're professional fighter
chances are you've come across a back
kick you just don't use it in the UFC
when you're fighting another monster
because you might have to turn your back
whatever the reason you know there are a
lot of reasons but don't assume that
they don't know something that you
actually think you know because you took
tackle yeah but but if people could see
like like what exactly goes on before
like the very first step the bit you
came up with the ticket to that our
special oh yeah you know like you cuz I
I saw Chris Rock probably like I don't
know six months ago use the comic store
and he's going on after a black guy you
don't know he's in New York I saw him in
use up there and he was just literally
trying to figure things out yeah and
then even Dave Chappelle so I'm trying
to figure things out then you see a
special yourself crazy I love that when
you're like oh that was that yeah yeah I
thought you suck I know I know I just
first time I tried that back because
they were I was like everyone's like oh
how were them like they were just trying
stuff I'm no one to judge any comic I
was a killer just trying stuff out it
was yes something was a hell and they
tell going after me a lot of the seller
and and he'll be like he'll always ask
how the crowd was but I know he lists
I'm like oh they were good I was all
like I was trying some new stuff so that
but they're better than I just did yeah
you know more like Dave Attell is just
astonishing to me he's so funny he's
just people say he's funny though would
you say that about no one knows we go
into I think that's why some people have
to give a bad rap at female comics
because like they're not funny because
they're what they see is I see like a
[ __ ] 15 year comic doing a late-night
set or something like that and then they
say like a six year female comic because
they need women so like all right fine
you're good enough let's get you on and
then the f right after that another 12
year male comic and then go woman suck
it's like no no six your comics up yeah
right he's a beast
yeah Eliza's section around me I've seen
yeah some never do it they're great
they're [ __ ] they'll kill you know
again just like anything there's levels
to this game you get a heavyweight fight
when you're two and oh yeah like wait
yeah there's just certain level I want
to talk about fights I gotta go to the
bathroom piss so hard I gotta pee hard
let me I'll secure your hips you pissed
I'm gonna shake you out twist you all
gonna go pee okay so we're just gonna go
dead air and together and just send a
pic to Daliya conjure up a ghost we're
back from the fresh piss yeah it was
good such a good piss bro good job man
how clear with you guys real clear Hydra
Mattias vodka I had I went yesterday for
the Rams game that was like brown like
the tea you were a very dehydrated yeah
and then I was like I drink a bunch of
water but you can't be honest and get
your kidneys work I did not do that
chintz we jump some current events yeah
hold up what sure would give us the
update on tinder um let me see this
chicks your matching with so you know
there's a service I'm sure you par did
this one to where if you pay like
another 30 bucks it'll show people who
like you swiped right on you first
before you swipe wrap right on them oh
really
no I never did that I don't have that
kind of sadness in my life I needed to
make this happen so we don't show the
camera though but those are the girls
that obviously Francine is the hottest
one yeah which I don't even believe how
many BOTS did you get when you did this
thing I'm gonna fake fake accounts
Basia tons by the end it was like
annoying limiting please let us see
these yeah awesome 30 my ass well
Francine is a yeah she's a model look
easier or no yeah
Lindo with the right diet could be
bangin with the right diet right now
she's not diving no she's like an old
car you know you even put some work in
good
she's for ting wow man well she's no I'm
not mad 40 chin
no she's 40 she's 40 miles away a set of
tits on her no chin one you drive for
that although let me see this so well
she's 70 miles away I'm gonna go with a
professional there she's about thanks
she's a professor yeah I think she's
probably under hooker yeah oh really
needs help with her rent no I don't
think she's a hooker I think she's uh
just looking for a little help the best
was tinder in northern Thailand because
the names were hilarious like shampoo 27
and then it's like clearly a [ __ ] but
then she wouldn't describe it and
they're like by the way I'm a [ __ ]
also in case you were [ __ ] wondering
I don't want any surprises later
tree-branch when I reach down to be an
issue so Jen so you got three yet let's
be real yeah matches what's the next
[ __ ] step it's quite well that's
going great man how are you at reaching
out like what making the first move on
he's terrible yeah you you know you know
communication just leave the matches
like I guess I have to actually start
talking her side damn mm I just loves it
let them ripen it'll be great it's real
easy oh yeah little forget about we got
a boyfriend and then be like you didn't
fail that friendship what's your name
Frenchie what's your name who's the hot
one on the red ship friendship yeah
that's right yeah yeah Francine no he
[ __ ] swipe she's getting meanwhile
you're sitting here
your dick in your hand yeah it's not in
my hand well good anyways yeah all right
yeah I you I see you on this I don't
know you see Jim finally post the video
of him singing I did not have you get it
wasn't a cabbie trip though sure one's
awesome get laid I'm not gonna bring
that up in a long time you bring that I
mean ours he now is Jim please bring up
that in singing really yeah oh you tryna
get matches or not is a panty-dropper
you didn't have it ready to go plays a
guitar okay where is this where's
actually this isn't a silver Woodlake
it's like the closest thing to real
forests and camping around here please a
[ __ ] money charts all right
[Music]
pat-a-cake Baker's man
by yourself right great voice Thank You
let's explain rate six with the Asia get
yourself a boyfriend and meeting I mean
Korean that sings country he's a badass
I'm telling you chin and oh my Jake's
smart country talented guy handsome man
that remember uh so I had a couple
friends come to the show Jessica they
were awesome you know I always say like
it's really hard for me to find my type
yeah that girl that I was talking to the
entire night Moke show that is my time
you can remember immediately every guy
started another at dick not ask for
number well he would talk to her the
whole time and then you didn't talk to
her all are nice and and she's recently
single and your friend that's her cousin
wait why would you let me pass well
cousin she brought her out for me that's
what she said cuz you you're so freaking
picky I just I'm gonna throw your bone
here and then she brought her up for you
and I hit it off and you're like guess
what else let her and you're like well
see you next time and say I'm friend
lives in New York that's awesome
no that's awesome we'll make it work la
no she lives in oh yeah why is that
picture of you hugging me there on the
Instagram this you nursing this no oh my
someone made it it's so heavy so small
there oh my god that's so creepy
so maybe that's hilarious cuz you always
said gigantism whatever so they made of
Tony Robbins you were that big umm so
chin you so you hit it off with that
girl yeah we're talking about I saw my
own two eyes you're talking that girl
alright and then you're like well see
you never know so on I've been asking
like the girl that knows her I go dude
let me know whatever you know if if
there's a chance whatever and then she
texted me about like she said there's
definitely a connection so it's up to
you and I already message that girl
they're cool I'll do nothing you still
haven't sent a dick pic tonight so might
as well you know what that'll bring your
chin mask yeah get her used to it now
I'm gonna be a little bulkier than Chi
I'm not gonna lie to you
you know they get around because some
people's chest telling everybody are you
kidding me Cleveland that's not why they
no massive big dump some girls just no
no but I like it but don't you mention
it now you mention it alright let's see
what's going on what do you got Jim yeah
so the first one is obviously the Canelo
Alvarez versus triple G fight what did
you guys think as far as who won and the
scoring first of all both you see it you
actually watch it you watch highly I saw
I did I have no edges in boxing that's
fair I want like your honesty
I like how at the [ __ ] judge Adelaide
bird sounds like a [ __ ] first lady
from the 1800s she doesn't look like I
thought that for me they're like I was
so impressed with Canelo in the first
three rounds he was he's his speed he's
so fast and his and then he took some
shots from from our boy but this note
from me
there's just no question gennady stood
in his grill and boxed him in the corner
after corner against the ropes and
punched him and landed more shots and I
had Gennady
100% so how could fight who judges get
it wrong then so so crooked crookedness
in boxing so wait the lady Adelaide Burt
she got it she got it
18:10 the wrong way yes somebody's also
had a draw so that was also wrong you
gotta say though at least more fair but
also wrong also wrong yeah it to me it's
clear as day to judge I you know I I
gave Canelo rounds two three then I can
see get him you know two to three rounds
maybe after that but his footwork was
good early on he had you know his cardio
was good but then it was more of I think
triple G being so respectful to Canelo
and then once he's like oh here we go
like I've never seen Triple J so nervous
in my life for a fight never you so
conserve conservative in the first like
four rounds then once he got in his flow
he just took over there's like a tidal
wave he just took over yeah
then it wasn't much of a fight and
listen man my girls from same hometown
as Canelo my house is [ __ ] Mexican as
[ __ ] like I was rooting for
Canella man and I looked at them I went
I I'm sorry like he's getting just
outclassed like it's not much of a fight
he's getting and they went I agree and
then you know I I you know I said this
on rogue and I said if triple G does not
stop Canelo he will not win in decision
they're not gonna let him win boxes been
around for how long it's always been
like this do you have those dark
tentacles just involved in the sport and
people won't say you know McGregor
Mayweather was a [ __ ] show [ __ ] show
this is a way bigger black guy than that
what are you talking about because like
was like an actual - it's an actual
fight combat that a guy clearly 1-click
you don't have to be a boxing expert to
realize who won my girl's mom who is a
Cavs I mean she only watches Canela
maybe twice a year doesn't know boxing
at all was like oh my god poor can hell
like not even close like it's so easy to
see what is happening here and then when
you have the the interest so imagine
this imagine in the NFL do you watch do
you watch sports and all - okay so
language everything's about them all
right perfect
so let us say in the NFL the the
Patriots before the Super Ball had a
huge dinner and had the refs who were
gonna ref the Super Ball the next day
they had them over and they were all
just having fun having drinks
that's what homeboy did the week of the
fight I didn't know yeah they do they
have these dinners and they have the
judges are sitting down with deltoid
they're sitting down with the
representative no yes and there's
they're there pushing them like you know
my guys good you watch out because those
body shots do more damage than you might
think
is it because they are the judges they
must be getting the only waxes they're
getting paid off hundred percent they
are getting her percent then they say
she got like 30 grand shifted into her
account there's been a judge who they
they can prove got 30 grand
sent to the account but with her you
know she's already watching me grow even
even the Nevada State Commission the
head of Commission was like listen she's
usually super reliable she actually
teaches other judges I take some under
their wings there's like a bras on he
goes I don't know if you have this
article Ching this [ __ ] goes but
everyone has a bad night and she was off
that's
head of the Nevada State Commission
going everyone has a bad night but she
was and she was off the [ __ ] you can't
have a bad night as a judge you millions
of dollar is the guy who said it was a
draw that guy had a bad night I got a
bad night he was off you're just a
crooked [ __ ] so this at least Burt has
she had bad decisions in the past but
not forever oh yeah yeah yeah she's not
good not for it she's not good yes she's
taking payoffs write it down though he
took her off the water of the judging
board for a little while like a break
Cecil people's continued to [ __ ]
judge you up see yeah it's crazy when I
was like dude he's hurting our sport can
you please just not have that guy it
goes no I'm gonna keep doing it and then
people on my Instagram people and
Twitter are like oh you're telling me
UFC you don't have a bad decision
[ __ ] we've been around since like 2000
- we're good
we don't know how - we don't know how to
figure it out yet we're still in these
growing process you've been around for a
hundred years
we know the sweet science there's
nothing new and I'll just pure
corruption there's not much good do not
corruption on our part good judge now
it's not grudges I don't know it's not
that far we have pure corruption that's
a [ __ ] problem you're getting here
hey and here's the other thing triple G
and Canelo will not rematch their fight
will not be next and now I bet triple G
fight Saunders and I bet Canelo fights
Lemieux why because it doesn't match it
again it's like oh if I'm trouble genius
like according to this like I know I
beat you you know I beat you yeah why
are we matching just well the only the
only reason I would rematch is that now
triple G knows and is not afraid and
we've never been afraid there's not a
fridge triple G sir so yeah really
afraid a good we may actually be have
Canelo when the first it was a 10 pound
12 mm 12 if Canelo won the first let's
say seven rounds and there's like okay
he's but and then all of a sudden triple
G dominates the last five correct losses
but like oh maybe you just nervous
you're gonna we should do a rematch that
might be interesting but the public's
not crying out for a rematch is such a
lopsided fight so now what you can get
and it's gonna if they do that then you
can fight next make
Independence Day on the rematch but
you're gonna have to outside triple G
you know fight Saunders villager
Saunders and then you have Canelo fight
Lemieux those are two fun fights and
then have them back together immediate
rematch all of this is mute moot unless
you have an independent body that can
investigate these just for sport this
[ __ ] you need it's not fair where's the
independent investigator to actually do
a forensic study on their bank accounts
to see what the [ __ ] is going on as a
fan as a pure only fan of MMA it's which
is similar to boxing the two guys go at
it you want you want the [ __ ] release
of the guy who clearly want to have his
hand raised yes that's what it's just a
good end of the story and you don't get
that it feels gross it feels nasty it
was like like I didn't I didn't walk
away in the the boxing purist when
they're like the McGregor Mayweather
that's it
that's horrible farce war it's a black
I'm like this is a black at least
McGregor Mayweather there was a clear
winner one guy was clearly better
he got finished okay that's how it works
sure we're done with that in this oh my
god what are you talking about this is
the worst thing for you could free the
sport you need all these new eyeballs
Mayweather McGregor help this fight yeah
right help this fight because they're
like oh now boxing is a thing that's
right oh let me look at this apparently
this next fight is gonna be the best one
I'll watch it nobody's watching and you
have this kind of situation you don't
have an innovate you know it's always
gonna in Olympic boxing it it so there's
no more corrupt sport in the world than
box yeah it's Chris is all based on
judging unless there's a knockout it's
all down to the track but at this level
it's so tough to get a knockout at their
high size level you have these two guys
are so talented that's all so I stopped
watching boxing they just stopped being
knockouts and it's like I don't care who
someone says one wow you know did you
see did you see Luke Rockhold I saw all
that yeah what do you think of Luke um I
thought you looked alright he didn't
look great I thought he looked alright
he got he got hit with a lot of clean
shots from ranch I've just fighting a
guy like Whittaker he could be in some
trouble huh
if Bisbing gestured Lombard loss goal
Romero if he's fighting those upper
upper echelon guys he'd be in some
trouble
but again ring rust is real for his
layup for and eleven days wrong it was a
good tune-up I just he just took some
time off he's doing ma
stuff like that that takedown was big
for him but yeah it was a lot of
wrestling a lot of clinching against the
cage
I thought yeah I think I'd hit with a
lot of shots I thought Branch was
aggressive branch did pretty good when
he got to the ground but you know if I
told you branch was a black belt from
hens Oh Gracie you'd like really you
know though oh my god high level black
girl but he was in trouble Instagram um
I watched that that blonde bar fight was
actually good Anthony Smith was sitting
there in his face and I you know and
they were going back and forth and Lamar
was chopping Anthony Smith's legs out
was it pretty even too little yeah
Anthony Smith landed a right hand
buh-buh-buh-buh your eye Hall look good
you you're right halls fight they'd
start off with the the whole part start
off sick it was a good card there's a
funny but always chaos and TK that was a
fun card the worst card on the on the
whole thing was the heavyweights
dude there were two decisions yeah it
was a really good card the rest are all
submissions I'm knocking Wow grab hold
got rocked early on and came back to
knockout I'm Michael's very boys rough
guy what do what is his ranking Mike
Perry right now maybe 11
by Barry
so he's not on the top he's not right
taking their account that last fight no
he's always like for 100 lines it's
always like what what do you that might
put them in the top 15
yeah but he's calling out uh well oh
yeah I just can't wait to see who
Connors next fight is gonna be who you
think it's gonna be alright thank you I
hope what do you want
khabib oh yeah yeah I'd like to see that
I don't or although Diaz you can get any
time so do that in a year who cares I
feel like you want to see it again but
like there's no brush on that title
fight or non-title fight doesn't matter
I'll still watch that fight yeah that's
not a point at 55 yeah that's a fair
point
yeah do you think I don't feel like
there's any demand for Congress name
like his name not no you're not a title
holder 19 ranked on top three features
mother more of a demand friend a fika
bean I think it's like he sort of been
ducking him he should be getting this
[ __ ] he's great too um you know the
winner of Tony frozen Kevin Lee would
probably have more to say yeah they're
actually hiding could be doesn't fought
can't make a pawn out that's a problem
it's like it's just so good promise to
be be so unreliable like he at some
point mark in a fight at some point
that's like it's a part of who you are
man it really is you can't mark in a
fight around the guy you can't put all
this promotional money into them and
then book this huge card and let's say
they want to do in Russia like they
there's rumors yeah okay you can put all
and then does he make it does he get
sick again
does he not make weight is eating
tiramisu we haven't see him fight
Americans really don't know who he is
what do you do Tony first and I'd love
to see time very some cop sorted Fergus
that would be Coral he has to get
through Kevin Lee October 7 that's a
tough [ __ ] fight man yeah know what
else you got you what do you think of
people given branch
flack for tapping two submissions well
Joe he tapped from strikes he didn't tap
from a choke or anything so really yeah
so rock cold start him out branch turned
and then rock called hat would like Adam
buddy flattened out was punching and he
I didn't see that I thought that ref
just stopped it I know I know tap
what I mean what do you wanted to do why
is it like I have to be an imminent
danger of being choked to sleep before I
can say it in the back of the head it
just strikes when people tap the stripes
yeah it always people like it yeah it
always get the thing like what a [ __ ]
but it's like I'm I'm not defending I'm
not strong enough right now or have
enough gas yeah it's like rocked I don't
know it's all yours at that point when
you do that it's a go neck what I'm
seeing like his neck was there I'm
surprised Luke didn't go for it
why not just how much what time was
looking around how much oh that's when
you go for that submission oh yeah
people are getting flack especially when
you're a black belt you know yeah there
was four or five so 55 seconds left
my guys ran down punches on it's like
easy keep going forever it's forever
yeah that's 55 seconds when a grown
man's on top you punch you in the blue
Rockhold forever I did I just had to do
a promo on some like press thing with
are you 15 seconds to say what everyone
think I was just you know it's longer
than you think okay but I I'm a cop I
know so I did it and then I finished and
the guys a 2-1 oh my god I didn't get to
the whole 15 dammit yes alright the next
one is Kevin Hart being extorted for
money Zenith yeah look at it but yeah
very investigating alleged sex tape
extortion plugins Kevin Hart he went
public with it yeah yeah you've seen his
Instagram aha they went on Instagram
admitting that you know he cheated on
his girls like my paws on my girl kid
cuz the girl is gonna get was like hey
I'm a released this tape if you don't
give me money it was the girl who trying
to store is that right there keep your
mouth shut [ __ ] well so let's see
this is Kevin's actual response to it
you guys wanting in here this is it okay
I love yeah I mean she wanted the money
I love him too do they try to think
there was some uh there was some hockey
player who [ __ ] some lady and she was
like you know I took a picture of us in
your bed I'm gonna put it out to the
world and he's like yeah I'm single I
don't give you ten grand yeah with Kevin
it's [ __ ] toplin and this is his third
hence - like you can caught three times
these you're just bad at it it's just
bad you're that famous there's gonna be
people like story who this is a picture
who is she can that picture it's a video
you know not nowadays there was an
article in New York Times about how you
define rape on college campus and girls
a lot of like Betsy DeVos is like
there's got to be like some recourse for
the guy because she was saying a lot of
these cases are women to God they were
dating no they were dating
got drunk they broke up they got really
drunk they had sex and about six months
later she goes that didn't feel quite
right he gets brought up on a college
great tribunal as rape now it's not it's
not he can't go to jail but it's a civil
it's a civil case your oh you don't go
to jail your whole reputation and so in
these these two sociology PhD candidates
wrote an article and they're both women
about how you know it should be the
women that define it and the mention
define it cuz they're the perpetrator
unless they do it okay you can find
however you want just like your gender
but like but like one has repercussions
on someone else you're ruining their
life here's the fine however you want
you're ruining their life man and it's
like you know if you if you guys are
both drunk it something happens in you
you six months later you're talking to
your [ __ ] friends who are whatever
the case like it's like it really like
Kevin Hart
no one's drunk here no one's drunk yet
nobody's drunk here just reminded me of
like I'm sorry it just reminded me of
just like the world we're living in
where you know people are I don't know
man it's just it's it's a scary time I
came here why I'm not sure the
connection at all if you're gonna [ __ ]
a girl and there's a camera in the room
and you're Kevin Hart yeah that's where
you should stop I had a check a skank
cuz I mean you ever kill it you ever
like just like kill it
yeah yeah yeah and I mean I killed it it
was one of those where it's like just oh
you want a feels like a meal yeah and
she got she's like hey no sure your
laptop thing was open you weren't
recording us for you because I would
love to see that and I was like oh [ __ ]
no I wasn't have a great idea yeah yeah
but just the fact that people even think
it but I've never done that you know
you're single so it's
different animal artery yeah oh you know
I don't you know I'm saying like with
for Kevin
I'm Heejun wife you should have people
around where who's your help man Oh
phone if you're single or like a priest
or something like that anything we're
like you're not supposed to be [ __ ]
to the public you know how she letting
him take this picture how is he letting
her take that picture what's that
picture do we know exactly how it went
down
he's a trusting guy that's the picture
that's the picture well that's just the
screenshot of the video so there's a
full video somewhere so what so she she
took the video he let her to so there
must have been someone else another girl
in the room that just took a little
video of it yeah you know what sometimes
when you're rock hard he had two
diamonds in the room like [ __ ] laughing
feeling like king of the world a little
drunk and he's the one that actually you
know confessed instead of paying her
money
you just confess on it like that what
it's like am I gonna get if I can get
the footage back am I gonna know for
sure it's over or just get out there
Benjamin Netanyahu you heard of that guy
no Benjamin Netanyahu he was running for
I think he's a prime minister of I've is
mayor of Jerusalem at the time okay and
his guy was running against sent him a
letter an envelope said okay I got
pictures of you cheating on your wife
so here the options you drop out of the
race and you get all the pictures I
don't want him anymore I don't have any
news for them or you can stay in I'm
gonna believe season ruin you that way
so I mean you're done you're done by the
way maybe not Yahoo's a badass yeah and
he goes all right and he just called the
press conference and he goes this guy's
blackmailing me
but somebody with my wife I feed that as
a personal issue and has nothing to do
with this okay and type move he [ __ ]
went up like 30 points in popular in the
election elite commando Surry counties
and bad no he's like do I thank you for
that they care show your weakness I'll
show my strength and responsive [ __ ]
he's not hearing this low and she goes
to jail for that she can go to jail for
extorting
oh yeah absolutely so it's like I also
get the word out to these other [ __ ]
this will not be allowed this is
happen that could cheer the wives all
they want it's not a problem legally
dammit this is and by the way you're
ruining it for all the [ __ ] who want
to [ __ ] famous people
you want to go get that D'Elia [ __ ] he's
got a [ __ ] wife that's right
you put this out there that means nobody
gets that [ __ ] anymore Rach no dick
preach little skeptical [ __ ]
you're hurting women you're hurting
thirsty women you actually heard there's
always gonna be a couple of bad eggs
that ruin it for everybody
yeah God she doesn't look bad though I
mean I'm sure I'm sure they're hot as
[ __ ] yeah that's what Kevin Hartz go
over look at those [ __ ] $180,000
watching that show I'm sorry about that
the point I was making about the right
now what like college kids are doing is
they are they there is an app they're
trying to come up with an app and kids
are hoarding like they're [ __ ]
recording the whole day yeah or they
don't you sign there's an app now where
you can like where you go observe for
consent form and all [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are we doing now you would now you're in
the bedroom in the most intimate moment
you can't let things happen it's got to
be a contract [ __ ] yeah they're like
well it closed up but any problems like
I need problems most guys and most women
don't have problems we just I don't want
to slow down for some [ __ ] rapist say
yeah and the I in Justice Department
talked about like so they there's this
[ __ ] narrative that goes on at one
in four women are sexually assaulted on
college campus or and yeah the [ __ ]
the justice department like actually I'm
callus campuses one in fifty three so
for those still too many but it's still
one in fifty three and also the FBI will
commemorate statistics which have
actually been falling through thank God
falling over the years so there are
certain statistics that gets skewed
where you're like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about man don't get what bothers
me is you're getting in the way of a
good time
and get in the way of intimacy between
two people a [ __ ] list now now you're
gonna accomplice yeah you're two people
who love each other and just just in
case well let's [ __ ] free night
America are [ __ ] at a way lower rate
than they were than 90s they're not
sexual they're dead then afterwards
oceans are against sex the men have been
defang their alternative [ __ ] chins
no
real guys left all right guys three of
us should get a time shooter just plow
we'll just have him sign a consent
that's wrong every man a bunch of little
ladies all right so John Jones tweeted
out but how much cash you want fingers
multi-monitor eight figures here it's a
good [ __ ] you crazy yeah that's if you
ask for forty five grand you could get
that yes for forty all right yeah just
shut the [ __ ] up we had a million
dollars you know you pay that forty
though who knows if she's never gonna go
away for sure exactly like let's go I'll
go right to the cops there you go walk
off mm-hmm okay John Jones's tweet after
he failed the second the B sample when
that came in he tweeted this afterwards
he said dude the truth is I would never
do steroids I put that on my children
and I put that on my Heavenly Father I
mean everyone thinks it's a little weird
that he passed all the random tests and
the day he knew who was gonna be tested
that he knew he was gonna be tested he
tested positive it does seem strange I
don't think it means he didn't have it
in the system but it just seems weird no
my way off just so much to go into it
the problem is is in this drug tremble
owner will [ __ ] its girl in a ball in a
ball there's guys in like single a
double a baseball minor league baseball
and even Major League Baseball where a
lot of them have been busted for this
because it's in I think they said 27 or
47 supplements at cheerleading really
see that's the thing and it's like but
up at this point John Jones once you've
already had that [ __ ] you got it dude
you can't put a burger in your mouth so
easy for a stir so he's that big giving
the idiot or my only issue and I'm I'm I
used to be so like Oh John Jones's [ __ ]
he's so screwed then when I actually
looked into it and saw that all these
that that same supplement they test
pausing
my god well maybes not completely full
of [ __ ] my only thing is then but you
look at it from GNC in there because you
already have these allegations you gotta
be good to be more careful
you look at its history and it's not
pointing in the positive direction
because history is so bad but no one
really believes that John juice John
Jones the longtime juicer right that's
not the theory out there the theory out
there that how is it there wasn't now
I'd say the majority does think it was
you know I issue is this when you view
if you take a supper and from GNC yeah
okay so I know that like Cowboys Ernest
said he was gonna take some
anti-inflammatory and he [ __ ] text no
Vince key and he goes dude can I take
this no Vince goes don't don't take a
chance I have something for you this is
something else so fighters that really
are paranoid if I know I'm gonna get
caught by USANA I put and [ __ ] from GNC
in my body especially mom John Jones
without checking with the authorities it
does go a little boy that's fair and
he's not that stupid
so the jihad play I don't know if it
works for this the other old some
Oldroyd yes it's super old it's like
from the sixties it's like Russian dudes
you're taking the one time I know and
the other thing is though is you know
John the last time with those dick pills
yeah I never bothered with steak gross I
didn't that story at all he did not at
all what about with Anderson no god no
I don't know that's all though they
narrate those stories and public's like
I can get when Martin Lawrence had I
talked to a manager about Martin
Lawrence remember the story with him
being naked with a gun yeah I never like
he was dehydrated and then Mike the
manager goes have you ever been
dehydrated anything close to that
behavior yeah it's just a spin is team
did a spin but it's crazy to me that it
was just crack
it's like it works for some people
Oh dick yeah he [ __ ] with me chicks dig
pills that makes sense yeah yeah home it
shows up when you're on a post
psychotherapy you take that after you do
a stack of stair roll I do know guys
like BJ sometimes just the process like
BJ was taking this stuff for years it
was legal and then they said later this
can also be used as a masking agent
which masking agents unless I'm wrong
don't give you anything it just covers
up correct the [ __ ] you would do and so
BJ is like I don't do that [ __ ] I didn't
get the memo that suddenly this thing I
was taking is no longer laugh yeah yeah
and now you're gonna [ __ ] get man
didn't look like he was do right
BJ pens are known not to not do that guy
with with John's just a little different
because if you're under that much
scrutiny and you know for a fact they're
gonna be all over you yeah I just
it's like Anthony Weiner trying to keep
his Twitter and it's like Anthony you
can't because you [ __ ] up your man times
that you're bored up I don't use it
because it doesn't matter no one trusts
you with it yeah so at some point John
even if he wasn't taking anything it's
like you can't put any supplement in you
without really double and
triple-checking it man I just I don't
know man watching him he's got so much
fun
IIIi would suggest I don't know him yeah
I don't know anything about what this is
like but my feeling is that from my
periphery and from people I know are in
the business yeah and and from what
they've told me about how prevalent
steroids has always been yeah my feeling
is a guy like John Jones and a lot of
guys you know he probably met some
people who said look this is very
effective and this goes out of your body
after two days we know you know his
brother so both his brothers playing the
NFL alter super [ __ ] stud Chandler
Jones for Arizona's ridicuious all-pro
he got busted - yeah really oh yeah and
that was Terrance you know so you're
telling me so let's just extrapolate for
a second really you got a guy who's that
bad special he he took he took a random
bottle let's see that somehow somehow
had yeah next let's extrapolate this I
just don't I don't know how you would do
that i I just a tough sell sense it's a
tough you're gonna take these what I
mean if you give me a protein shake I
swear to God if I'm if I'm dead I'm
gonna go biggest fight of my life what's
in the protein shake bro what do you
mean monk fruit what do you what I gotta
see me sober alcoholic and someone hands
you a drink yeah even not at a bar
correct you ask what alone millions of
dollars online ate an entire career
correct so I don't know it just doesn't
that I mean tomorrow sure take the
random thing but it's a day the day of
your fight don't take that to it this is
what else bothers me about it if it just
sucks it if I was convicted of testing
positive for steroids I would I don't
give a [ __ ] what my PR
team says one man says I would like got
on the [ __ ] horn told everyone
hey up front of my house get out of here
I'm gonna tell you guys I did not
[ __ ] take a thing correct I took this
look I took this [ __ ] suck I guess
right this problem I'm just this protein
part from GNC that's all I [ __ ] did I
just were - god I beat these exactly
right him going silent and then trying
to come up with a story rounds wait on
leaks correct yeah you do wait when you
stuff when you're like I've done
something wrong let me figure out how to
how to come with a good lie around it
you don't when it's like no I did not
like right away somebody accused me of
getting creepy with somewhat my friends
X which is just not true
yeah and I might just kill yourself why
do I kill yourself not like well it
might have been this it was like no you
don't wait six weeks to respond you go
you go you go hold on Oh
his lawyers probably I keep it quiet
well let's see what this man I'm like no
not [ __ ] you guys this what's going on I
didn't do anything so they're not gonna
find anything oh it was a something from
Jim see I couldn't find it in my bag I
took this this what test pause right now
test this right now
that's right there you go there's the
old bag I did nothing that's right but
then being quiet and trying to come up
with a story now man
yeah I just does some because I loved
watching a fight and it's like I won't
now for a prop I mean they're not you
know what but no no see you won't miss
him I hate to say it at the end of the
day it's just what the Train moves on
who do you think is next fighters the
trains not moving on the trains moving
like this so when you say they're not
gonna miss them they're gonna miss the
[ __ ] out on will he tell spike every way
I'm saying the fans you think the fans
oh my god he's all the second biggest
draw I have no I have no interest in
watching a dinner cornbread fight
no one toward the title no it does like
the the he was the one star he wasn't as
big as Conor Rhonda and Brock he's the
next heir he was by far the biggest and
he's been gone he's been gone yeah it
was barely fall everyone likes that
story what do you think now what do you
mean he's saying this I'll tell you
right now is next his next fight Jon
Jones Brock Lesnar WWE in WWE
yeah sanctioned not who gives a [ __ ] the
fans will watch who cares if it goes on
his official record yeah
massive you're 12 roids not for roids
who gets some fake [ __ ] maybe that's
why I call that Brock Lesnar in the
Octagon - because it's like hey I'm
gonna be a lotta fight here much longer
so uh so let me set up my next play what
do you what I we don't know but I mean
no she's they're more investigation
right now well the Commission has
decided what they're gonna do they're
gonna look at all the evidence and then
you know he's looking a four year
suspension max we've already come down
as hard as they can on him before they
don't like was that a two-year
suspension or is that a year suppose
yeah the UFC's RI stripped him of his
belt so you don't have to be some pretty
serious [ __ ] hmm at this point I could
see the UFC going listen
you pulled out of a fight for something
else bad behavior pulled out of this
fight now then now we fight and now
you're if I can overturn honestly I'm
sure we could make more money off you
we're no longer interested yeah go help
Strikeforce go help whatever yeah we
don't care there's no longer interests
yeah even though you're the best we
don't know in your back we're just going
to move on good chance switch to the new
owners new owners right three more it's
the new the Disney owners
yeah the Disney owners of the Willing
morris though they don't give a [ __ ]
like if Jon came out and they're like oh
we like like oh we [ __ ] up he actually
it was a product and then he hit a
pregnant lady they need rating so bad
they would keep them in so as you ever
see suffering in big ways and in ratings
mm-hmm
you think it's because of the the biota
because they put on [ __ ] a fight
every seven days both yeah they don't
got so much I don't have the Stars
you're oversaturated the testing so
strict the marketing yeah it's a whole
it's like the perfect shitstorm right
now but get out of it there be new stars
but right now they need Jon Jones
support seems like it's evolving faster
now than it was 10 years ago so that
your star light star goes two years
instead of eight years correct so it's
hard to really keep track of what you
got it seems our guys being able to
break down your game plan right mm-hmm
it must be much harder yeah
sophisticated teams who are solving your
hole right is that you think that's fair
yeah I don't know it's kind of a running
backs we're like guys great and then
tears later like run back to solve like
three three years and that's it so you
can't really keep on that wasn't always
- right tony dorsett played for what ten
well there's our what is that
there's outliers but in general they're
always a short they're always short when
you're Gregor Pro Bowler and then all of
a sudden you're like you got cut what do
you use a promo to years ago it's like
Cleveland like you know last year was
Cleveland its bummer what's he do now
but he packs groceries but good he was
had some good he's at Papa John's this
you texted me this yesterday that oh my
god [ __ ] terrible
oh cool dude so this kicker I was
talking about he's a kook who's the
first Cranborne kicker in the NFL he's a
piece of a cake or one like the Ray Guy
Award and I was telling chin about on
the big round breakdown how big of a
deal I was like I'm rooting for this guy
and for the win
we lost in the game
[Applause]
[Music]
he barely misses had the distance he
missed last week statements last week
game time last week but yeah so his job
is on the line now apparently they could
have been to a no it was a better guy in
there yeah no yeah exactly alright he
could be to a no man if it were him to
know at a new March you know in your
Korean in a new market trying to like
get fans to like appreciate this new
team yeah you're fine you need to have
you need to be like four and four and
have a chance of the playoffs
and they're all the same so it's like
yeah you need Sebastian Janikowski
you're just some guy plus your Korean we
already don't think you're invading no
[ __ ] satellites in that in that
football because the Korean man
ethnically Korean man but he is American
yeah he's [ __ ] man so he's a rookie
that he's 1 for 4
oh yeah they're bringing another guy in
this they're easy to replace there's
always a guy who's not even in the NFL
who can do fine yeah what happens to his
contract then we'll leave nothing you
get no money no you can know that the
air don't you know [ __ ] look at pay out
the year no damn that sauce no it's no
guarantee playing football you suck at
your job man shrink you paid if you
bombed every night at stand-up would you
get paid
no but if I if I bombed on Wednesday and
Thursday and Friday like we don't need
your presented a you still got a payment
for Saturday I came out here under the
contract that you're gonna pay me yeah
chill but different yeah they don't
they're ballers they're gangsters the
way that most years really bothers one
for for yeah he's done [ __ ] it dummy
not maybe somehow Korea over you were
United North and South with hatred of
the sky several I think I'm just want to
think of several and I like your
thinking
did you see Teddy Atlas go off on a
decision it wasn't the Canelo Alvarez
decision but it was this one s condone
against K have a cave 12 Bronson I think
and what s condone one he just talks
about the corruption in boxing but he
goes off like crazy let's say I love it
decisions including one judge you had
117 - 111 for us I love to them Wow
seconds just what did we see loving this
guy gets mad look I could take 10 years
and it's been years and years of the
same garbage the same trash I have no
choice I've been in this business 40
years of life whoever I'm gonna go don't
know where to go if I did I get the hell
out of it I get that watch these
fighters that put everything on the line
they get in the ring they come out of
the ring with lunch of themselves
physically then they had when they went
in and this gets topped off by a bunch
of cowards and took a punch their life
I'm sick of it I will say this tyson
cave has a family and children that got
one more burst thousand dollars down the
line losing this fight he did the same
thing with those right with the last
Pacquiao fight
he kind of went off he slammed that it's
gross horn it's gross Teddy Atlas is
like this is terrible
what do we do about it how do you solve
the problem keeps happening you've got
it you got it you gotta investigate
you're a drug going to realize you know
how do you go around the NSA city you
can't say you got your own investigator
independent investigator a commission
and they go and investigate this [ __ ]
they do a forensics accounting to see if
who's getting paid off you do all of it
and you can do it you can get to the
bottom of it but you have to have the
will and the Commission everybody else
has to have the will to do it it's got
to be a political decision yeah if you
don't do that you'll never clean up
boxing and they don't want it done
because they want to keep it crooked
exactly Brennan let me ask you a
question about the Ultimate Fighting
Championship and how they do the refs
there do they rotate them randomly so
that no one could pay them off it's I
it's up to the Commission's that Nevada
or whatever so like going in when you're
headlining do you know who your
reference you know turn the locker room
they come to you before the fight in the
locker room right before right before ok
like I feel like I'm Big John me ref
tonight we don't know ahead of time so
like even we might even once the fights
have already started let's say you're
the 11th fight yeah so by the third
fight would you know oh you would know
you wouldn't know
okay right when you get right when you
get to your locker room punkah you he'll
come in like Big John or Herb Dean or
meza Gotti and the by camy ref tonight I
always wondered if they go over the
rules just rotate him randomly so no one
could pay one of them off for the beasts
of manner but no there's been no
allegations of that though a ref get
involved and now never UFC decision
never good question though thanks a lot
of chump he retweeted a gif I don't know
if you guys seen this gift it's a good
gift right I don't mind the gift that
memory tweeting it but his jump okay
there we go like about it he makes me
laugh Hillary so I know it's caddie
city's a [ __ ] pretty good golfer but
he's funny maybe that's a big shank
though he's hitting an airplane that's
not in the fairway yeah that's right did
you uh dancer you see the Emmys last
night
no what the hell [ __ ] no job dude oh my
god Stephen Colbert they went so hard at
Trump they had Spicer Spicer was he
rolled out like the White House like
podium no yeah and and and I was like
this is the biggest event that anyone's
ever seen I'm not lying here like it was
crazy funny that's funny they went so
hard at Trump it was insane Cobra I
heard did a really great job amazing he
hosted it yeah good for him he did an
amazing job
let's get you what else you got pretty
much it other than this thing which it's
not that big of a deal it's going far Oh
though someone's feet we're creeping
into the side of a girl's chair did you
see it's got cute feet that's funny man
it's like no one cares about anyone else
oh that is kind of gross to someone else
it's not that big of a deal it is boy
this is going vivacious no honey no she
looks funny
it's like rg3 always be a big a big guy
lady no no yeah I would slap my hey come
on you doing reasonably area that's a
late
a lady down the play lady who gets upset
about I said yeah looks like rg3 Donna
I'm not trying to be mean things are
just great she has a strong face strong
job he's Don the league
yes Griffin yes I guess he is that it
Jim that's it
boom boom got you a little dropping
knowledge here uh I wanted to say that
there's a lot of talk about hate speech
and there's a lot of talk about if you
read sort of on I've been reading about
these college campuses this [ __ ] you
[ __ ] here's why you're allowed to say
that here's why that has to be defended
as reprehensible as that might be when
people say well your hate speech is
making me feel stigmatized is making me
feel under representative isn't hurting
me the problem is that speech the reason
speech is in the First Amendment and is
protected is because it's effective yeah
okay so so speech is very powerful
speech gave women the 19th amendment the
ability to vote speech was where women
got up and screamed in the street it was
so prevalent in the Civil Rights can you
imagine if the Civil Rights didn't have
people screaming and shouting for their
rights even when hoses were being turned
on I mean dogs were being turned on them
that is what freedom of speech does it
wakes people up and it and by the way by
the way when people were marching in the
streets for equal rights black people in
the South that was very offensive to a
lot of white Southerners but that
doesn't mean that that speech isn't
protected so you have to protect speech
because it's effective because sometimes
it's very effective at being at getting
shaking up the power structure and
giving marginalized people their rights
because it's effective that same power
can also believe it or not offend a
certain subset of the population
including good people good people and
bad people it's a double-edged sword so
that's why the First Amendment is very
important so colleges about 300 them
universities pass
what's called hate speech legislation
which is you can't say anything that's
offensive to me and you have to own your
impact so when you say something like I
don't know how that is Osso them so
they've all been defeated in courts
because the First Amendment says no even
though it might make you feel
stigmatized or upset you not allowed to
do that now in a dorm you can't hang a
confederate flag but you can't say in
the law is very clear you can't say
you're not allowed to hang a confederate
flag but you can hang an American flag
you have to say you can't hang any flags
you can't have a bullhorn and come into
a classroom ago [ __ ] you all white all
black people suck you can't do that cuz
you'll get kicked out because you're
disturbing everybody with noise it's not
the content all right it's the yelling
it's the noise and it's the yelling and
it's very important to make that
distinction and it's very important to
protect hate speech it's very important
to protect the ability all speech
because because it has power to make
change and move because the other side
of it is has a force for good sometimes
gonna be used for a force for good bad
here's where the big distinction is if I
use speech as a true threat to you so if
I say Brendan kick that [ __ ]
ass good look and you're right there and
you start beat them up well no I good
luck and good news good news good news
and you get your ass kicked and I
haven't trouble yeah right you would
have affected your friend Brendan that's
exactly right that's exactly right you
have a gun in your hand I go shoot him
in the face then then I can be I can be
held accountable because that was a true
threat yeah but again when you start
with saying that your speech hurt me
yeah your speech was and will you hear
this on campuses all time this is where
we're educating our young people your
speech was violent toward me we you
better be very careful because now
that's open annotation and it's against
the First Amendment and there's a reason
the First Amendment has to be defended
for both sides and that's very very
important for people to understand thank
you for holding my hand
I think people also say like sometimes
you're not allowed to say we're gay or
that we're alone yeah you are I say
I'll tell what hurts my feelings those
business such as you're telling that
story yeah that's a good shabbos I said
what were you gonna say Arianna to say
some people say like yeah but if it
leads to violence like it did in let's
say Charlottesville yeah then that
speech should no longer be protected the
problem with that is well then black
lives matter has led to violence that
guy shot two cops so you may draw that
distinction this way you know you don't
you'd say that guy who ran somebody over
should we put correct you know whatever
because he did yeah yeah and no one was
saying I want you to go run that guy
over right you saying Jews go home Jews
are [ __ ] killing our society look I'm
a Jew I don't like defending that but
like let him talk
yes and by the way because when you say
that your speech led him to drive his
car and you're now extrapolating the
never again that word you're going not
his family life is rain k so he just got
there walking by and he was got brain
Washington so that go it's amazing how
how freedom of speech the First
Amendment is constantly under attack
cops always work and you've got a
decisional let's go outside let's just
scream en word out loud and that's good
that's good racist
defend my rights definitely wall high
one screamer I got in trouble for
dropping those n bombs was hard on them
right yeah pretty much
stand up wise is his comedy wasn't good
he's already off stress in the store at
first people he got that but like all
cool its but I'm like a vegetarian it's
crazy in two weeks people like beat it
yeah jock not a good comment hasn't
worked that way does no not the store
not the store back then we terabyte saw
many times he's not he's a great actor
he's not a good comic but what they want
to do is they want to ban the n-word and
say you cannot to say it but as an
English major and as a comedians
expression expressionist I'm like we'll
hold on and we're it's mean it's hurtful
but it doesn't mean it should never be
used like what if you want to hurt
someone but if you're looking to find a
black eye you know like I want it I
don't know anything about you and I'm
looking to hurt you well then that's a
great word it's a perfect word it'll get
you upset so you can't just suddenly say
like don't say certain words it's like I
don't know there's time in a place for
everything yes there use guns to kill
very important to is to realize that
then what you can do as a white
is go that black guy called me a honky
now that becomes just as offensive
because you have to have objective law
you have to have you can't just you know
but it's like right legislation around
one word you'd have to define what it
means is their violence attached to it
yes but that's not enough
yeah but like right people when they
were saying hang that lynched that end
yeah you know that that would be that
was that's why that word has so much
yeah you know people actually do it but
the real problem is that they go a Lynch
that young man same it's like he's gonna
get lynched is a handsome black young
man I think it's also like honky doesn't
really have the same effects or sudden
hurts like if a girl let's say a woman
like a small woman what's your name
again
MJ punch Brendan like it wouldn't have
the same damage let's say is Britta
Brandon because colleges colleges are
trying to protect people from opinions
and ideas my opinion and my idea there
might be very offensive to some people
yeah and and here's here's how you fight
it when somebody comes to your campus
with what you consider to be hate hate
speech because it's always subjective
well you considered me a hate speech
okay you have a right to do two things
one leave or to Marie
counter-demonstration know close case
you have a right to counter demonstrate
with your words so you have a right to
counter their speech with an argument
with your own speech that is the
principle is valid because they want
their voice if I get a shitty restaurant
or slow service you should just like you
know what I'm going next door but you
don't that's not enough no you got what
everyone you know you want to have them
yelled is hurt yo yes God words have
power
it's what led to great change in this
country and in other countries to
women's rights to to gay rights to black
to brown and black what rights the words
are powerful thank God they have power
and what if you have something it's a
not a gun can be used to kill a bad guy
or a good guy it's the same exact thing
don't outlaw don't clearly sell don't
outlaw words all the First Amendment
being a Maremma do one better
kill each other there you go that's the
man that's an option to thank you for
any shop yeah all right they can get
your stress right now on Netflix brother
yeah I didn't get my special it's called
double negative it's a double two-part
special damn good yeah so you can I hear
great things yeah that's good
I like that Ari Shaffir you're a great
man you're the best and you're a unique
[ __ ] and a very honest person I
find you to be a breath of fresh air
thanks it's hard in this [ __ ]
business you're Jewish what happened no
oh no hate speech what you say is a joke
I said my people suffered oh so it's
okay to jump so how people survived the
genocide and now you come in you come in
joke but you're real funny didn't you
grab Hasidic or Orthodox up Orthodox
heavy Orthodox heavy Orthodox you had to
pray all the time and got to pray would
you wear pants got two pair right and
did you wear pants yeah I had up a
little bit do you know this do you know
the Torah inside and out I know pretty
better than you but like yeah most
people but it's you know I've slipped so
yeah but nothing new has come so it's
not like I've fallen behind the Jews
were the great innovators and still are
one third of all Nobel Prize winners are
Jews you want matters one we appreciate
come on brother yeah that's why I belong
to come on it for a long time no we've
been trying to make it happen man yeah
like right after you guys got like going
I know we'll see you then why about it
and the next thing we're back out here
okay we love you man love you too
this is a fine kid we're out